[Music]
hi guys
so my first lecture for seth lewis chess
club
on
end game madness
uh and will be dedicated to a class of
position
um
that are fortresses
when uh rook and
a piece fights again the queen
okay so called a pendulum defenses
so
you see the position on the board
when the base of a pendulum the bishop
on c2
and
the rook is
going back and forth between a4 and e4
so uh no nature of those defenses are
very easy to understand the
rook has two scores to go to
never allow the king to coming
okay
queen sacrifice is not winning because
well there are going to be no pieces on
the board
and coin along cannot do the damage
so the concept is extremely simple but
once it's put in on in
practice there might be like a
you know
there are some tricks and you'll see it
uh
we're gonna go
look to more and more complicated
uh
situations and
you'll see that even something very very
simple like this
can be
tricky okay
all right so here obviously yeah rook
just goes back and forth
draw
nothing really to explain next one
okay so not only bishop can be the base
of the pendulum defense but the knight
as well absolutely the same idea
nothing really changes
rook goes back and forth
cannot cross the middle of the board
draw
the only way
the pendulum defense can be broken it's
some kind of a took time when the queen
comes closer
and but
as long as rook has two squares to go to
back and forth supposed to be a drug
okay
so
all right another example of uh
uh
of the pendulum defense now as you
understand uh it could be bishop on e2
route goes between
uh
b5 and h5 and king cannot cross the
sixth rank all of it's all the same it
is just a draw
here root goes back and forth b3 and d3
okay
all right cobin now
let's see how it works in practice
vladimir acoben uh it's not varus
nakoban don't
do not
confuse one for another okay another
super strong um
another super strong armenian player
uh
leader of the team for a long time
before
aronia okay
and
uh we're gonna go straight to the end
game straight to the
key moment where black will have to make
a key decision
and we'll see
if the pandolin concept will be easier
in practice and you know
was an explanation so here okay
how did white wanna
coin
all right this one
before
and black
sets up
sort of a
defense
oh
first of all
what uh what what is the black setup
where the bishop has to be in whether
king has to be where deruk has to be
or making it a pendulum defense here
where where the base of a
pendulum should be
so that the rook has two squares to go
back and forth
now bishops has to be on d8
rook f6 b6 going back and forth
so that's where the bishop belongs
right
king has to be like
doesn't matter where he is it has to
defend the bishop
it can be on e7 on a8 and the rook goes
back and forth between
f6 and b6 if white king goes to c5 no
the rook better go to the other side
right
if king goes somewhere around here and
threatens to sacrifice well the rule
goes to the other one
and
it happened for a while
okay and then after a lot of maneuvering
after a lot of maneuvering white
we'll
ask an ultimate question
h4
bishop b6 and g4
okay
we saw an example of pendulum defense
which way you're going to be taking this
point
well make a wild guess if
that's a problem
but i want you to understand why you're
making this decision what's the
okay you see what's going on right
anyway we're taking this pawn the other
pawn goes forward and then queen
eliminates all the black pawns with
checks
or maybe not right away but eventually
so
white will end up with the pawn on the
king on the king side
so he will take like for example if we
take h takes
g4 i'll play h5 he will have to take
and i'll take with check i'll take on f5
and i'll take on g4 and the same thing
happens if i'll take with a f point
so the question is which way
he'll take one of them as a draw the
other is loses
you take with age pawn and the reason
for this
it ends up protecting your
the the
rook is not going to be attacked in the
same manner
as it moves down the board
um
okay so if i'll t okay if uh so you're
saying taken with the h1 versus f1
because
the rooks will not be attacked i think
it matters whether the rook attacks or
not it's just uh
uh you mean that after if i'll take with
the f pawn that f5 as a tempo
it's not that important because
i know
uh
even if it's not it's
even if it's not a tempo it it's all the
same what's important it which important
here important part is which pawn we
want to leave for white to remain
alive
f or h
so you see i'm taking the pawn and then
white
plays like h5 or f5 and this pawn will
be eliminated too
so only the last pawn will remain so
what do we want for white to remain on
the board h porn or the f point
and it's very important
it has to be an f pawn right because
again the base of the pendulum will be
on
d8
so the rook will always be able to stop
b pawn and the f point
if we'll leave white h pawn on the board
then it just doesn't work uh the rook
can and the bishop cannot cover h6 you
see that
so the h point will be simply queening
so the correct answer is
this
okay
not the other way around if we take it
with the f1
then
just this
rook f6 should not really help because
i guess just here
okay
and this position is lost if i'll have
to take take because there is no
pendulum defense anymore or
h
rook and the bishop will not be able to
stop h pawn and this too
really nothing against the queen so
correct answer is
h takes this is the way uh
michal krasenkov uh took it and that
holds the draw
so takes like i said
white picks up the rest of the pawns but
it really doesn't matter because
bishop goes to the d8
and that's it
going back and forth
that that's the nature of a pendulum
defense okay
if uh for example if white had like a
gp1 versus instead of f1 that would be
position will be lost for black
okay uh
and by the way it's a good question was
it was e pawn uh
yeah it was e pawn it should be lost too
it's just like uh
this one it's
not doesn't matter why try it but you
cannot win it because well
as soon as the king goes to the one side
there goes to the other side and then
i'll start moving the king around yeah
so
king has to be close to the bishop uh
king has to defend
the best of
this defense
okay
keep going
uh shuba pogarilov
yeah
it's the
same thing
again let's go quickly through
let's go quickly through the game oh uh
white was completely winning in in the
middle of it and it's just uh
for some reason decided to
to go to the end game like this
which still pretty good chances but
after a while
it takes takes
after a while we'll end up with
it's hard to imagine that block was able
to
even get to this position oh my goodness
knight takes b7
check here
check
king is 6
e4
okay
so we're black here and
we don't want to lose it
what should be the setup for black what
how do we place our pieces
so we need to set up construction so i
want
uh
i want you to tell me where the knight's
supposed to be and when where the rook's
supposed to be
night on d a
perfect yep so you you got it
that's what black did knight d8
check comes here check here 26 e5
check and through came to and it's
impossible to bridge uh
white will try it's not don't oh yeah
actually he lost the pawn right away but
even if
he would like
yeah if he gets to d5
yeah but you can't win the rook yeah uh
if king gets to d5 and rogue gets to e6
you cannot sacrifice the queen for the
rook and the knight
because king gold is defended yeah
okay very nice uh
next one
okay well sometimes
uh it is a draw even if uh
king is breaching you know the perimeter
and gets inside
all right
thanks to the knight because it's like
such a jumper and
possible forks it still could be a draw
and this is a nice example
that even though king is
inside the construction and threatened
the base just because it's white to move
it is a draw so check
again check
and
and you get you got to go outside of the
perimeter and yeah go outside that's it
rook rook d4 d2
and it's like no longer
can be bridged okay
all right
okay this is a
a problem
uh
so
yeah you see it's uh problem from all
plus i think
from 1945.
uh
no you see what the problem is the king
does not defend the base right now so
and if base if construction is broken i
mean
it chances are becoming really really
small so
how does white
get
back into into the construction uh this
one doesn't uh
no check doesn't make sense i'll take
with the check right
so how does white make a draw here
no i guess the first move is
pretty obvious there is no defense which
is
what
the starting off
uh if knight moves away queen c2 picking
up the rope right
so knight cannot move
uh rook moves i'll take a knight
so the only
move
knight
another three knight of three currency
two check
right
id is correct but uh
while we're moving the king
remember construction as the king has to
defend the base right into d4 yeah we're
going closer to the knight
okay black goes king is six i'm still
want to
no
okay
and now
ruka 425 check
so what's the second move
not much of a choice so
white is it's white it's white it's
white smoke rook is under attack yes
okay
rook f3
queen d1
d3
okay
check
and king gets to the base
it's like a baseball right
get to the base defend it
got it okay
uh
and we got construction in place already
and just a drop yeah
okay
so let's look at the exceptions to to
this rules like so
where it
doesn't work
so we looked at when
construction works and
this will be when they don't
so boris gulco uh
many times u.s champion plays black
pieces
and that's
from his
early
um
games 1972
oh my it's yeah 50
almost 50 years ago
so
very interesting line
and
black is doing great
okay
white was
probably was doing fine
g2 here we go
takes
takes
a knight of one okay
so let's look and try to understand this
exception
so
white sacrifice to piece
and moves to knight f1 so looks like
he's ready to set up
pendulum defense with rookie 3 and rook
g3
the difference is opponent g6
that makes position winning for black
why this is winning because
yeah because basically
well
and
oh yeah because we can go g3 that's the
reason yeah if g g3 was not possible
there's no pawn on g6 that's a draw
but because of that extra one
that breaches the
like uh defense and
this is a win
check check
here
and
no it's winning in many different ways
and f3 and just
that's pretty nice took time
couldn't be selling
and rook has to move
no i guess it was not the only way to
for example
uh
queen f3 should be winning two here
but uh goldco found like a really nice
way to do it
okay
uh bernstein robot
um
let's see
what's this game doing here
okay
check a5 a4
here we go
g5
g4
f6
okay
why this position is winning for black
if we remove a pawn a5 and a4
just a simple draw
on
black will have to play a 5 at that some
point
white will take
and then create like a pendulum
construction like pretty quick i i know
knight can be moved backward like to g1
for example um
g1
no e2 e2 yeah
e2 and then rook goes between c3 and g3
but because the a pawns are on the board
the position is lost so it's another
exception for like why this fortress
doesn't work here
we will see
pretty soon why
uh
why it really matters so that a pawns
are on the board
so after like a long maneuvering finally
black realized he has to go
and
yeah you see um it's lost because
black and white can only set up the
pendulum construction on the third
right but then he cannot defend the pawn
on a4 if the pawn would be on a3 and we
could have a rook on e3 and g3 draw
but
it just doesn't work and disconnect it
and
and if it's not a pendulum defense it's
just an easy loss because no queen is
still powerful
oh actually he managed to do this and
still loses oh yeah he loses because
queen
king does not defend the base
here we go check
yeah the slots it takes
knowing that that's an easy one uh
a point will cost
okay
keep going load next
this was okay we're probably not gonna
let's switch the color and go it on the
white side
we're not gonna go through the whole end
game it just i want you to like visually
recognize if there is a chance for a
draw or not
so
right
so this is the position on d5
takes takes
okay so we
saw the previously that uh with a bishop
on d8 this position is drawn
because
uh
with the knight on d7
it's still lost so that's another
exception it's like
even though this pretty much the same
construction right uh there are little
twists there is a little twist
so with knight as the base of the
pendulum two pawns are
hard to hold basically the reason is
because knight can like only cover six
right and the board is eight if board
was six it would be a draw but with the
eight the king goes around and to the
gets closer to the knight on d7 and the
rogue cannot do both stop the kick from
going in and no
let's see at which point uh the king was
breaching the defense
it's theoretically it's theoretic win
it's just uh
you'll see it wins on a tuk swank uh
yeah
at this point a a white plate queen to
d8 and
you see how he cannot go to
f6 because i'll take it
cannot go to d6 because of qnh2
and kin cannot go to b7 because of a
queen d8
so it's a two trunk position and uh
he had to take here but dao king gets
closer to the
to the night the whole construction
disappears and
white wins easily
yeah
okay
load next all right
let's move to something like very very
simple
uh
what happens if the pawn
replaces the bishop as a base of candle
okay this is uh again the rules are very
simple
this is elementary draw and you don't
even have to like worry about it uh
rook goes back and forth king cannot
bridge uh
there's no took time because well brooke
put back back and forth
exceptions
okay
uh no exceptions are very easy to
understand uh by yourself the rook needs
needs two squares two defended squares
to go to
so the only pawn that doesn't give rook
two defended squares is what a or h
right it's going to be only one defended
square on g6 and b6
so is the pawn on h7 this position is
lost
it's kind of
pretty straightforward
another exception that
you just need to remember
is when the pawn is not on the seventh
rank
when it's not on the ceiling but
honestly anywhere uh higher than seventh
rank it's lost
because the reason
you can guess what the reason is the
king gets from back from inside
from behind and then it's a took twice
so
let's see how it works oh
it just i don't even like
now i mean
sooner or later rook will have to allow
the king to go in and king just goes
from
you just need to know the
uh mechanics how it works and you will
figure it out over the world don't you
don't even worry about so if you know
that uh
pawn as a base uh not on the seventh
rank but anywhere higher
even as high as like
fourth
it's it's a loss because king goes from
uh
from behind
okay
all right this is this is another
exception okay
uh
looks like the pawn on when the pawn is
moved to h4 i'm taking one of the
squares away from the rook and the rook
left with only one square to go to e3
but
this is exception this position is drawn
so it's
still there is something to remember
and you might ask like how well why how
this knowledge is a practical like when
uh
it is
when uh position is too complicated and
you're looking for drawing chances and
if you know that
f
uh
f and the rook versus h one is a draw
you can save a lot of end games like i
did
and
really you don't need to know how this
happened it's enough to know that this
is a draw you will figure it out over
the board
okay
so
okay let's see
how it looks in practice
two israeli grandmasters
played in 1994
some interest in binoni and uh
white one quinn
looks like he's cruising to victory uh
no until
not really
okay
26 g5
and e4
oh we don't need this pawn it's not
gonna
check
h5
queen on
f7
okay
if you're black here and you want to
show why that you know what's going on
and let's tell you
uh
that you're not gonna lose this game
what would you play
i really love this move that the guy
like was
in the other guy's face you know i mean
there we go
black his bishop is under attack yes
how the black demonstrate white here
that
it is a draw like i mean
nothing to play for
that he knows the principle you know of
pendulum defense
so we need to move the bishop the
question is like where
will continue to play on and uh
okay
yeah i'll play king g4
okay yeah i just want you to just
uh
see this i mean i really loved it when i
first saw it played bishop f6
so it's a draw and i know that right
it's just like
so rook
goes f6 and d6 back and forth and uh
that extra pawn on the side
doesn't make any difference
the white cannot touch one black
and uh if you don't take a bishop go
just take g7 i'll take it there
but
bishop f6 okay the guy
uh
uh
who was a long
time coach to borrow his girlfriend you
know for many years and just demonstrate
like
that
he knows what's going on
and
it's just to draw
so white right it's not like he
but i'm go back and forth
and take it on f6 doesn't work and taken
here because
oh yeah because
like let me just show you that uh
it's a little unfortunate for white but
it's going to be a check
oops
b5
f4
b6
here
yeah unfortunately for white this is a
oh actually if it's not a check it
wouldn't change much right okay
uh
so
yeah
there's why it cannot cannot bridge
defense here it was a draw
safe um no
ilee and janewski alaska uh
this game was extremely famous i know if
you
know why
anyone recognizes this game no
okay last year at the game the first
game about psychology in chess ever
written
i don't remember what's the name of it
that something probably that's what it's
called psychology and chess
and he gave this game and as an example
of it so
uh elin janevsky who was like a strong
russian master at this point
played 92 here
offering queen trade
and according to lasker and his book
like after queen takes d2 no even though
for modern player it's
pretty far from maduro still according
to laska
thought the position was
dead even and it's a draw but
laska wanted to win this game and so
what he did
he intentionally
went for
a worse position
after queen takes a2 queen takes a two
loses a queen
and here we go white wins the point but
lasker did it intentionally because he
wanted material disbalance
and so his opponent no longer can play
for a draw
white is better here and he needs to
play when you're better
you need to play for more otherwise
you'll be worse and
white
lost this game and that's how it made
alaska book
okay but it wasn't that
you know straightforward and clear
i think at some point
uh at which point by the way
oh okay no
uh we already yeah we're all ready to
pass to pass the topic uh it uh
this game was a part of a bigger bigger
lecture
that on
queen versus
different
material like rook and
rook
and the light piece so let me see
if uh
we got a little bit more
of the
keras
okay
yeah so we change the topic a little bit
uh in this in those games
it's
no longer a fortress it's just a queen
versus uh
rook and the light piece
so this is a pretty famous game
from 1939
versus caris
check
knight g2 d4
f4
d3
takes
takes oh
i went a little too far yeah okay
uh
here's scary sacrifice the queen
with d3
for
a bishop
and
the rook
and won the game so uh ever played rook
f2 if he goes king king h1 after rook
takes e6 he
completely paralyzed the
black brings another rook plays rookie 2
and he's done
so he tried
to do it this way but
it's just too much again
it's a beautiful finish by
okay so it's another like classical game
it's a beautiful one
okay
so let me see adam's ivan took okay so
here uh
this game uh
is to demonstrate that there are a lot
of system in the opening theory uh
modern opening theory
when one side
intentionally goes for the end game
donna quinn
against the rook and the peasant
uh
because
well they just believe that the other
side cannot win it so this game
demonstrates one of those lines
so i don't know if you know this line
it's the sicilian dragon
okay
queen d2 knight c6
d5 and
if uh white plays king b1
uh
the following thing happens the white
black takes on d4
and now if
y takes it back after d takes e4 block
position is completely fine probably
slightly better
but e5 that's the main idea of the whole
thing
now the knight goes away i'll take on f6
and knight takes d5
and suddenly
queen is in danger because
i threaten knight takes f6
and win
so knight f5
takes takes and knight takes d5
so
what happens i'm threatened to take on
f6 and win the queen
uh if
bishop goes away
i'm still going knight f6 and when
so looks like a very difficult situation
for
black
uh
what do you think he can do
how did ivan choke escape from
from this
tough situation
any idea
you take and then fork when he takes
very good queen takes d5
so
black is going to the end game when he
only got like a bishop and the rook for
a queen
and i want to demonstrate that uh it's
probably
black who's played for a win here
right
but you know michael adams always been a
good defender
he held this position even though he was
under a lot of pressure
so perfectly lined up bishops the rooks
are all
totally participating and now i want to
goes even for more okay
so it's not enough for him that it's uh
rook and the bishop for a queen he says
okay well
how about
just two bishops for a queen
i'm not gonna lose it okay
so extremely
interesting conceptual play
for white
rook d1 uh
if black takes on b2 he's gonna lose the
sun game
but he doesn't have to take it's just
nothing much that
white can do king is absolutely safe on
g7
uh
white has zero uh
the winning chances here
so
when you play an end game like this so
you definitely uh
it's useful to to know all these
pendulum defenses ideas that we
discussed today
okay
so let's see what else is there
[Music]
what was that
oh yeah that's another
line
where
one side sacrifices
sacrifices queen for the rook and the
bishop early in the opening
uh so let's talk about it a little bit
more
in more detail so quincy too
uh
bishop d6 no
very well known position in them in the
slav
uh
i got
i got the line here that name
after uh
me and
my friend
alexis sheriff it's called
move g4 here it's uh
shabala's share of
attack of its love defense
but
there is this tricky move e4
and this is one of the ways black can
react to this is to go e5
takes takes e5
idea that after d takes if i block
castles and
[Music]
well
i'm threading knight takes e5 get the
pawn back if needed like rook e8
and
well the only way the white can fight
for the advantage in a position like
this is to suck the queen
to go it's another theoretical position
on
bishop e3
now i know
when mommy drf analyzed this
thoroughly he he won this game pretty
easily
b5
no black
already isn't
in a very difficult situation here
and mommy drf won like a beautiful game
too
very impressive play
on his part
just one
okay
this kasparov anderson um
another example of the line um
it's in catalan
defense
there is
this one castle knight c6
and queen a4
takes
and white takes
knight takes d4
after this move
bishop takes c6
bishop c6 and rook d1
so the point is
right now if black takes on c6 then
white takes takes
takes on d4 then takes on c4
none thanks to those weak points on a7
and c6 well white will have an advantage
in descent game
so what anderson did
here instead of going into this
very
unpleasant end game
he said
let's play this one instead
and even though
you got like a
queen versus on the rook and the bishop
all i have to do
he says i only need to trade a and c
pawn for the b pawn if that happens
i will easily hold like four and four
coinverses because
all those panel defenses and
after a little bit
kasparov
yeah
just here
rook lined up against the c file you can
win the pawn on a7 but you're going to
lose the pawn on c4 knowing then chances
to win it
are absolutely
non-existent
he didn't even try so this position is
another like it's not a fortress yet but
uh
you know there would be like a even uh
remote
uh
winning chances because power will
continue but well he didn't hidden
four and four
or three and three rook and a live piece
against the queen on one side
fortress
so
submit slick wonk uh
oh yeah there is a line in
grundfeld
which is exactly
the same that we just looked because
power find it but with the colors
reversed
so take stakes same thing
but
that extra tempo that uh
white has here compared to previous game
allows him um to actually
fight for more
and
white won this game
you see how hard like a
black to develop pieces and now he
finished his development but his queen
is
no
i mean after bishop d1 black will win
i'm sorry white will win coin
so this is what happened very very
nicely played
by uh ukrainian grandmaster
the
yeah so black has to do this because the
queen uh
queen is trapped
again bishop d1 there's no defense so
the only
way
is to sacrifice to rook but
two rooks and a piece
is is a winning position for white is
this a safe king
yeah it works
okay
and let's see if there is some more
oh yeah okay
so this is probably the most uh
most famous example of this end game in
practice
uh super super
famous game of caries versus fisher
from
curious was it 59 curacao
but you know what i'm talking about it
wasn't neither
okay which was queen f3 castle knight d7
and kerris played this move
bishop e2
which
was
which works very well if black for
example goes h6 here
right h6
bishop h4 and now knight d7 then this is
the best move in position
but
here bishop e2
fischer played b5
and nope i i'm sure it's one of the most
famous fishers game
okay takes takes on d5
i'm sure you've seen it before it's like
a
position
i mean white's fight white fight for a
draw but the funny part was that after
a while
okay
oh
white could have played better before
that we're gonna come to
situation of the pendulum defense we'll
see it uh
right here takes
takes and rook d4
so
now rook can go back and forth f4 and d4
okay let's switch it on black side
so f4 and d4 and according to
our
like
rules today
it
should be a draw
no
the difference is unfortunately those
points on the coin side
and even the white a black has two
points versus three
whites on a block position is winning
so and fischer demonstrated it's
amazing technique
queen c2 yeah so white king
overlord is overloaded he cannot defend
the base of the pendulum knight on e2
and the pawns on the queen side
so this way
pendulum defense does not work
so
a4
yep so kin d2 already queen b1
so knight c1 check
takes
queen c2
comes back
and yeah the constructions there are no
more
right there is no base nothing and queen
simply becomes uh much much more
powerful than the
white pieces and the f1 will cost
white
a rook
so
yeah double connectors win
so this this game is is very very famous
and uh
no again after today uh we know that
only the pure
pure cases of a pendulum that have
chance
against the queen with like a few
exceptions and if we have like a two
extra points on the other side of the
board most likely it's going to be lost
so and
to the trained eye at immediately
recognizable entity
so
i guess
i believe this was my last
game in the file
okay let me see
machine aronian uh
well
since
leon is in town
uh
he'd probably be
would be better if he talks about this
game himself okay it's
absolutely crazy stuff you know the
white had like so many pawns for the
or over here
uh
i remember when this game was played now
everyone was absolutely sure
that it has to be a draw like with just
way too many points
and it wasn't
like
if there is no pendulum defense i mean
the queen is stronger than
it was absolutely crazy game i mean
whatever it's
uh
black one
and let's see if that's the end of it
okay
just
yeah 30 seconds just for uh to update
your
portfolio of like
uh
winning and drawing positions so we have
a rook piece
at two
points
it's theoretically winning
and
the we saw it like i'm showing you right
now i think uh caleb uh showed it like
in his lecture
uh
carlson beat nippo and
like exactly so uh knight rook two
connectors
it's a win it's the long story but it's
a win
it's a theoretical win and
so
same goes for the bishop
okay
same goes for
[Music]
for the bishop
and
what else is there okay yeah and then i
i got like a
bunch of examples of uh
how the queen is stronger than the rook
and uh
and the light piece but that's already
outside of a scope of our lecture today
and
i think that's it and um
thank you guys for coming okay i hope it
was useful
um
it just
yet another situation on a chessboard
that
that you're now familiar with
okay
i would say
to my coach uh
one of my coaches the grand master
brigier was that he was saying that
the only difference between grand master
and just a regular player is a
grandmaster knows about like 10 000
typical situation more
and this is one of the typical
situations that we discussed today okay
so another like 9 000 plus
okay well i'm kidding of course but uh
yeah this is how
um
this is how it works uh it's
on
this next time something like this
happens in your game i mean you'll be
better than your opponent so
i hope
it will help
okay
thank you
talk to you later
[Music]
you